[Musique]
tu es une ville de boulangers oui je le suis je suis là pour
te dire si tu n'arrêtes pas de coller
ces pancartes partout dans la ville je vais
être vraiment en colère vraiment qu'est ce que tu
vas faire me battre ou une centaine  ans
et vous devez laisser ou trois pieds de haut
mr.  Rosenberg viens à Shabbat Shabbat
ce papa
J'espère que l'étrange aventure dans laquelle tu
te trouves t'apporte le bonheur d'élever des cochons
en Israël tu ne pourrais pas jouer au golf comme
tout le monde
[Musique]
congédie moi coupe notre fille et
ignore notre fils pour ton cochon ridicule
famille oh mon dieu tu as vraiment une
crise n'est-ce pas
tu me suis non tu vas à un
rendez-vous je vais visiter la
tombe de ma mère je suis désolé je continue à
t'écrire malgré ton silence c'est  c'est toujours
une question de colère face à mon
annonce franche combien de temps ai-je
quelle mineka pour ne pas voir leurs
parents vieillir s'occuper de ta mère
ouais un ami rabbin ils vont te rendre
heureux
[Musique]
faut-il  déclarer l'amitié comme
on déclarerait l'amour je pense que oui Lonnie
mais avec toi silencieux